in other world news Sudan's power
military rapid support forces have
denied responsibility for the killing of
the West Darfur Regional Governor the
Army earlier said the paramilitary group
had killed kamis AB bakar in elginina
earlier a bakar had described the
situation in the city as a genocide the
latest conflict between the Army and
paramilitary has reignited long-running
ethnic tensions in the western Darfur
region let's speak to Al Jazeera Zain
bazravina who's in charge in the Border
Town of Audrey where thousands of people
have been fleeing the violence in
westar4 then I know you've been speaking
to to people who've come from across the
border there and I'll ask you about what
they've been telling you in just a
moment I seem to have lost connection
but if you can I will go ahead and tell
you that the death of that senior
official the death of that senior
official in westar4 has changed
something at this border crossing today
something has changed it is prompted
what seems like an ex
of people filing out of the city in
larger numbers than we've seen in the
past certainly exhibiting signs of
serious injuries we're just looking at
someone Crossing in now clearly who has
suffered serious injuries people that
arrive here need immediate care they
need immediate medical attention they
arrive in grave condition another thing
that's changed is we are seeing more men
and more boys
seemingly leaving the fight in Al Janina
now whether they are members of this
tribe or that whether they are security
forces or civilian whether they are
police or soldiers or fighters of any
kind it doesn't seem to matter here men
women children everybody here is showing
serious signs of human suffering of
going through the experience of the
siege of a city in this current century
now another thing that has changed is
there are no Cars on the other side of
the Border being bringing people across
everyone's on foot many of them totally
Barefoot and no one is Crossing with
belongings here there was a kind of War
economy in place on the chatty inside
where people with horses and carts
people with taxis would show up to fairy
people with what belongings they had
into the safety of Chad that is no
longer happening people here say it is
too unsafe we've been hearing
intermittent and at times sustained
gunfire where the sound of heavy weapons
as well so there is active fighting
still we can hear it from where we are
and security has been beefed up by the
chadian government north and south of
this Crossing Point concerned about the
violence in elginina as seemingly
al-jinena begins to fall into the hands
of the militias perhaps completely we
are seeing the chadian security on the
border being beefed up the hope is that
it doesn't go any further than elginina
next
Zayn thank you Zane Bas Ravi live there
in Audrey Chad